hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transitions.com
so in this video guys we have something
new coming on amc on triple q on bitcoin
uh i will show you some cool things on
amd as well
um and i want to discuss with you the
potential reversal that might be coming
sooner than expected let's get into it
all right guys so
um
let's go step by step first amc then gme
then i'm gonna discuss
what i'm seeing on the rest of the
market and of course it can impact it
will impact amc and jamie so let's start
with amc as usual
um
so
like i said in my discord i posted
yesterday
an alert so basically since we have um
this increasing volume as you can see
here the red bars coming
i was starting to be bullish um
and
i suggested to use this trend line as a
stop loss
and as you can see here we had a nice
rebound i didn't buy here let's be
honest
but we were starting to have some
bullish signs coming in
uh in this market and
i posted um an alert yesterday so
basically we had
uh and the reason being that we have all
the indicators pointing towards the same
direction so let's go through it we had
the first increase in volume that was to
me a first signal here then
uh on thursday we had another increase
in volume
so it's good to see this it means that
bulls are back not back in control but
that there is something happening and
that bulls are attacking this is what an
increasing uh green volume means then if
you look at the rsi
like i told you guys an rsi that is
stuck below 50 is bearish another side
that is above 50 and that is bouncing on
the 50 mark is bullish and here look
what we had so we had a first here rsi
coming higher than 50 for the first time
here
all right that was a bit early
but it was the first signal and then as
you can see it was supported here by its
moving average
then here it was let's be honest below
the 50 mark all right
and then finally on this
big
volume
green bars it went above and then
support here and then we went above so
what i mean is that the rsi was bearish
here the whole area here expect here a
small fake out and since here
since
june 27th
the rsi is bullish and now we are in the
bullish area so only looking at the
volume in rsi i don't even need to look
at the charts i know that was in control
does it mean they will keep control of
course not it just means that they are
in control that the like that it's more
likely that we go up tomorrow than down
that's all it means
um
then if we look at the price action
uh the press action is a little bit
messy let's be honest but what i can
find is this triangle all right so the
lower band is pretty obvious i think
that all of you guys
have seen it um so that's why i
suggested to use the stop loss just
below this trend line
um and the upper band i put it here i
have one
two
three four five reaction and yesterday i
mean thursday so two days ago we are
saturday now uh we had a breakout above
and we closed at the top of the candle
during breakouts those who bought my
course know that whenever we close at
the top of the day this is very good for
the next
day
so
this was looking good and we went up
only one percent but
it's uh it's still a green day it's
still very positive we are we're
confirming this breakout uh the only
thing that i'm missing a little bit uh
we clear above actually is the 14.5 uh
resistance it's not a strong resistance
but as you can see we had here three
reactions even you know i'm i'm looking
gen 22 guys one two three four five six
seven
uh bam eight and nine we had nine
reactions on this trend line for the
past uh year six months and now we close
the booth so that's positive i mean this
is bullish guys there is nothing else to
do amc is bullish now how far can it go
let's see
um the next resistance is
so let's be precise here actually the
next resistance is 16
16 is the next resistance
okay
and then we have something
wow
the price action was so messy that we
have things everywhere 16 17 and
okay 18 as well is one yeah he's 19. so
that resistance is all the way up okay
uh i can't give you anything very
i mean clearer than that
16 first resistance 17
next resistance we even have something
at 18 i mean all right there's
resistances everywhere because we can
see that we have um we don't have any
nice consideration the best
consideration i can use is this one so
let let's just be pragmatic here and use
only the recent past because otherwise
it's too messy so then 16 is the first
seventh in the second 19 the next one so
three resistances levels on the way up
and the major resistance
is created by this trend language right
so remember what we are trying to do we
are trying to know whatever amc
downtrend that started uh in june 21
whenever this downtrend will be over to
know that we connect uh the highs of
this move and as you can see we have a
reaction here in march 22 so this trend
line is the trend line we need to break
out above for
something huge
uh could happen all right so we're gonna
monitor that
uh so to conclude an amc bullish next
resistance uh between 16 and 19
and i think we're gonna go test this
trend line sooner or later i don't know
if it's gonna be on the move that we're
gonna have now or maybe you know in in
in one month or two months i don't know
but we're gonna test it probably uh
during the summer
so around 19 21 i don't know when it's
going to be
and this is going to be key so that's
why i put uh a question mark here now
jimmy
so bam bam bam
jimmy uh same thing guys so just to
compare those two
uh
the amc 21 level that is created by the
trend line is gme
150 level roughly all right
um
so what is jimmy doing
it dropped today
uh bam bam bam we had nice volume here
and um
we have resistance around 140
that is created by this triangle
and i told you guys that here we might
be doing an abc it's possible so maybe
we're on the third wave all right
that could go here maybe i don't know uh
it's too early to say i don't know the
price action doesn't give me very clear
signals so let's analyze the same way we
did for amc
strong volume strong move up we closed
at the top of the day but the day after
is
you know not nice we don't have the
momentum keeping here
the rsi is at 51
so above 50
you can see that gmu was holding well
above the 50 mark it dipped just below
now it's back here
to me both are in control here on the
medium term uh short term it's not
obvious i'm not sure but medium term we
are bullish so
it looks like we're going to test the
140 level next week sooner or later
probably in two three days i would say
um and if we of course break below 115
we are not bullish anymore all right so
above 115 we're bullish we're likely to
uh go higher i don't think we're gonna
test the 115 level uh because it has
been tested already it seems that the c
wave might be complete
um
and yeah what else can i say yeah that's
pretty much it so we are
i don't have a strong view on the short
term on gme
let's be honest but uh i'm monitoring
what is going to happen between 140 and
150 level all right and here of course
we want to see this breakout that would
go together with amc breakout above
uh this trend line alright so this is
what we want to see now i told you guys
that i have some good news all right so
let's go through it it's coming from
triple q
and uh the good news i have guys is that
we have a breakout all right and it it
it's been confirmed
so as you can see uh since the whole
move down all right since this breakout
and i was here guys uh to tell you that
uh we are going to move lower for the
coming month
uh this was in jan 22 all right
and this is what happened all right um
so the question is is this correction
behind us
it's hard to say it might be early there
are some good news about maybe we're at
the peak of inflation uh we have some
inflation data data coming next week
and something is telling me that so we
are i think we have 8.6 forecast so
roughly same as last month
uh and something is telling me that the
demand has dropped a lot and maybe we're
going to have a positive surprise on the
inflation meaning the inflation will go
lower and then everybody would say oh
look the inflation ping is behind us
everything is good we're gonna um
we're gonna go higher
uh possible maybe i don't know let's
watch this figure it's gonna be really
key guys
so bam bam bam
let's check when it is exactly
okay so 8.8 forecast
on
july
13th all right it's in four days okay so
it's going to be it's going to be very
very important to watch this number but
look
even before this number we already have
a nice situation so
let me get rid of this first so that
just you see so this was a resistance
all right guys this was a resistance it
was the c wave very clear one two
three four reaction
five and six all right so after six
reactions a trend line is getting weaker
i was telling you that there was a sixty
percent chance of breakout here
okay uh
three days ago now i changed my
probabilities because the breakout
happened
i personally had a short position on s
triple q i uh stopped it
uh almost fully and i sold a call
whatever but basically i i don't have
any short left
i'm playing the move up i think we are
going to go higher for the next two
weeks once again the reason behind is
this inflation that might be behind us i
mean the peak
i don't know to be honest as you can see
on my chart i'm still bearish on the
long i mean medium term let's say on the
coming two months i think we're gonna
have one month off rally let's say
things clearly
um and let me explain first so here as
you can see
we have uh
this breakout above this trend line with
a nice move up and we confirmed the next
day so now we are clearly as you can see
here above this blue trend line right
those two candles are clearly above
uh and here we had a nice consolidation
not nice but it's it's a consolidation
once again i remind you guys we like to
see the price actions uh really close to
the trend line to create energy so that
you know bulls are preparing their
attack they're gathering their strengths
uh and uh this is what we call a build
up and after the build up then we can
have strong moves so this is this is an
acceptable uh build up
and now we have broken out above that
level all right so
uh for this reason we're likely to go
higher
now
where could we go we could go to uh 315
it's the most logical level because it's
the recent high and then we would have a
question so i think we're going here we
can of course fake out okay it's
possible once again the volume is not
strong
but it's not always strong we don't
always have here for example it was
stronger all right
so we had this massive move up
here the volume is a little bit low so
maybe we're gonna fake out
i put a probability of 20 of course this
is very subjective i gave 20 i could
give 25 i could give 15 you know it's
just to give you a rough idea of how i
feel about this breakout
i think it's strong enough for the
probability here to be quite low right
now so the probability will drop heavily
in the coming month to me is very low
that's why selling puts
selling 270 put august 19th of triple q
i did that is a smart thing to do
because
it's very unlikely to me that we close
below 217 august as every dip is likely
to be bought
right now so i'm not saying monday is
going to be up maybe it's going to be
down but if it's down i'm pretty sure
that tuesday is going to be bullish now
investors are going to buy the deep
again because we have this bullish
stimulus coming that is once again
coming from
the hypoth hypothesis hypothesis
uh sorry that um the inflation is behind
us the inflation
um
the increasing inflation is behind us
maybe so then we would go to 315
uh and here i gave a 30 chance that we
are bullish right away okay it's
possible and the reason why i gave 20 uh
last week so now it's it has slightly
increased because we are moving higher
um
and
it's not impossible look my scenario is
here one two three four five remember so
fourth wave and then bam fifths so it's
not going to go here it's gonna go here
it's pretty much the same
um
i still think this might happen but it's
gonna depend really on the inflation
numbers if you have i don't know 8.2
8.3 inflation next week
i mean
i would be very bullish on that because
it would mean that it works that the fed
policy
uh what they do increasing rates is
really really cooling down the economy
enough so that the demand you know
people just don't have that much money
as before and so they don't spend money
so the consumption is going lower so
it's not good for the gdp of course but
at least it's good for the inflation so
this is now the
thought process that investors will have
and i believe that
um it can work and if it works why not
you know
having a bull market coming in two
months or you know something like that
it would come here in september
so anyway i'm gonna of course do some
analysis for you guys whenever we are
close to 3 15. right now i think we are
bullish i might be wrong and we might uh
drop right so be prepared for that it's
possible as well now um i've seen a
couple of good trading situations
uh coming on stocks so the
one of the nicest one and i posted that
in my discord for those who are
interested i posted it of course
before i got in i got in the tread amd
update island reversal can still candle
stick pattern all right so
what is an island reversal an island
reversal guys is that okay whenever you
have a trend so here a downtrend and
suddenly you have a gap down bam so
that's very bearish right here we gap
down
between here and here and then we have
one two three candles this is the island
uh isolated candles and then you have a
gap up okay here you have a gap up
between here and here so as you can see
gap down gap up okay
let me remove that
okay and here is the island so this is
an island reversal all right isolated
island and this is very uh this is a
very strong
uh reversal pattern
uh quite rare it's not very you know
happens that often that we are very
bearish to the point that we get down
and then so bullish that we gap up all
right that's not a very usual situation
the last time it happened
it was here guys
i mean in my memory of course it happens
every day and i don't know where on the
spy guys here around 3000
to okay you see here this was an island
reversal
same thing all right in june 20 gap up
here and then gap down all right and
then it was followed it was not so
bearish
uh we gapped down
and then we went a little bit lower our
lawyer okay it was rather consolidation
but
anyway
this is bullish
uh the right way to play it once again
is to buy this is what i was explaining
in my discord yesterday is to buy
if we open higher than the gap up okay
if we open lower the uh structure is
invalidated the pattern is invalidated
if we open higher you buy whatever at
the open so i bought at the open
yesterday stop loss here below the
island all right simple so let's see
but this is a nice signal we had the
riven as well
i shared the straight idea with you guys
it's a more classic situation rsi
breaking out above 50
strong volume here on july july 6.
as you can see we broke out after
consolation above the strength line
which was
the original downtrend
uh retested moved higher i mean the
volume occurred only when we started to
move higher not during the breakout but
whatever
now we found some resistance at 32
i'm in this trade i'm happy to keep this
position you know and i'm not gonna go
through every uh stock uh that i'm
monitoring but i'm seeing a couple of
nice situations
rxrx as well i gave you this one not
long ago guys
it's still good um i'm trying to get
back in i got in here so it's a
pharmaceutical company
i got in here
around six i took profit between seven
and eight roughly uh and now
i'm trying to get back in so i didn't
share in this code i'm gonna share soon
i'm trying to get back in around 797
in this area
and and this is a breakout right you can
see downtrend breakout so i'm seeing a
couple of breakouts so
maybe the correction is behind us but
like i said look at that
i'm just be very careful guys i mean use
stop losses a fake out is possible and
for now i price a 70 probability 70
probability that we drop lower uh
before the end of the summer all right
you can see 50 20.
if we once we add 315 of course those
priorities are going to change because
it means that we would have gone up
but for now i'm there is still a
more than 50 chance that we make a new
low in the coming two months to me all
right this is only my view but this is
what i think and to finish guys bitcoin
have something very cool to show you
stay with me
on the bitcoin look
so
what is happening abc bam the correction
started in november 21 a b c okay so the
question we have is is this correction
behind us same thing we make here a
trend line we connect the highs and look
you're going to see this is not the cool
thing i want to show you i want to show
you something else i'm going to just
wait a sec
and here bam you can see we make this
trend line and it gives us a level right
now at 23 000. so i made two scenario i
was a bearish uh last week
now um i'm still a little bit bearish
but
i'm starting to consider that maybe the
correction is behind us because i'm
seeing a lot of bullish information on
the rest of the assets i'm monitoring
um
and here i think we might reach 23 23
000 soon and then question are we gonna
be able to break out above green
scenario or not and then drop and go to
the 14 16 area i don't know but if we
break out above 23 000 i'm gonna i'm
gonna be here to buy it all right right
now my bitcoin position is very very
small
and same thing here now the cool thing i
want to show you look at that
i just discovered that maybe you have
seen that somewhere else i don't know
okay
look
okay
i removed all the drawings
and i'm taking the bitcoin
forever i mean
the higher time frame i can and look
what we have it's really pure ta guys
reconnect the the lows
bam okay i was wondering why 17 000 has
hold
why we didn't go to 16 right away which
was the next support
and you see here
i was wondering why we
we bounced at this level and i was
looking here was that this is not a
support where is it coming from and i
found where it's coming from it's from
the original bullish trend that started
in august 15. you connect the low log
scale guys important the two lows that
we have here and look it gives us a
perfect reaction here
look at that i mean almost perfect and
so this is what is happening so actually
this bullish trend is still valid still
intact
and it's possible that we just go higher
all right it's possible we can also
break it and if we break it this would
be a crypto winter all right so here is
the deal guys either
we managed to stay above this trend and
we are safe it doesn't mean we're gonna
rally right away it can take a few
months
you see it can come back to this trend
so we can very well trade at 22 000 in
september it's very possible
um
this is the trend to look at
okay
so i think that we're going to really be
bullish once we break out above so
roughly 30 35 000 okay this is the level
to watch on the upside
on the downside
right now it's around 18 20 it's going
to go higher
uh and this is make this is going to
make the difference between the crypto
winter and probably a strong market and
a bull market coming back so we can
monitor bitcoin as well as an indicator
of the equity market
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and yeah i wanted to
tell you that i'm going to holy i'm
going on holidays today
uh to the south of france with my family
so i'm going to be a little bit less
here on discord of course i'm going to
check my phone i'm going to try to
update you guys a little bit in the
morning before going to the beach
and uh and in the afternoon i mean when
i'm gonna be back uh to my place over
there
um
and yeah that's it so thank you very
much for watching this video and don't
forget guys to click on the sub like and
bell button so you're gonna be the first
to know when i upload anything new and
stay close to shore see you guys